the sun
smooth and round and peaceful
except when it suddenly vomits radiation
and plasma in random directions
these solar flares and coronal mass
ejections or cmes can hit earth and have
serious consequences for humanity
how exactly do they work how bad could
they be and can we prepare for them
[Music]
while the sun seems pretty solid it's
actually like a very hot ocean
so hot that it rips atoms into electrons
and nuclei all flowing around each other
in a plasma
this plasma is pushed around and shaped
by the sun's magnetic field similar to
how the sun's gravitational field
reaches out to the planets and shapes
their orbits
but magnetism is very different from
gravity magnetism is one part of a dual
force electromagnetism
electricity creates magnetic fields and
magnetic fields create electricity
on the sun the plasma made of
electrically charged protons and
electrons creates a magnetic field as
they move and this magnetic field then
shapes the flow of particles
they're stuck in a dynamic feedback loop
called a dynamo which keeps the sun's
magnetic field alive
this magnetic field stores enormous
amounts of energy and leaks out over the
solar system
it carries with it a constant trickle of
solar plasma like a light rain known as
the solar wind creating a sort of space
weather
but it isn't always calm and smooth as
the sun's plasma churns and flows around
itself its magnetic field gets all
kinked and twisted
this creates magnetic knots that build
up enormous amounts of energy
when the magnetic knots break like a
tangle of springs exploding outwards the
sun can vomit plasma and other awful
things into the solar system
these solar storms come in many types
like solar flares a tidal wave of high
energy radiation they race through the
solar system at the speed of light
sweeping up protons in the solar wind
accelerating them into a high-speed
solar proton storm
then there are coronal mass ejections
which rip millions or billions of tons
of plasma from the sun's atmosphere
catapulting it through the solar system
at speeds of up to 9 million kilometers
per hour
when these monsters hit us nothing
happens on earth
while even smaller storms can damage
satellites affect radio communication or
will be dangerous to astronauts for
people on the surface space weather is
harmless
earth's atmosphere protects us from the
worst effects of a solar flare by
absorbing the blast of x-rays high up in
the atmosphere well before it reaches
the surface
the electrified plasma from a cme is
deflected by the earth's magnetic field
diverting the energy storm to the north
and south poles where energetic
particles fall into the atmosphere
causing the atmosphere to glow and
creating beautiful auroras
as with any sort of weather most of the
time things are fine
sometimes there are hurricanes though or
in the case of the sun solar superstorms
and we know that they happen once or
twice every century
if one were to happen today we would
first detect strong solar flares a sort
of flash before the much more dangerous
thunder
the thunder is a cme consisting of
billions of tons of hot magnetic plasma
that crosses the 150 million kilometers
between the sun and earth in less than a
day
when it arrives it causes a shock wave
that violently compresses the earth's
magnetic field and transfers energy into
the magnetosphere but it can get worse
if the magnetic field of the cme is
aligned to earth's in just the right way
the two magnetic fields merge
as the magnetic cloud passes over earth
it stretches the earth's field into a
long tail
eventually the energy stored in the tail
becomes too much to contain
it snaps and explosively releases its
energy towards earth
a geomagnetic storm has begun
a few hundred years ago nobody would
have cared this storm gushing over the
earth is not relevant for machines made
out of meat and bones
but it's very relevant for machines made
out of metal and wire
remember the dynamo
magnetism creates electric currents
earth in the 21st century is covered in
millions of kilometers of wires
transporting electricity and a complex
grid of machines like transformers that
make this transfer possible a cme's
energy can induce currents in our power
grid that can either completely shut it
down or worse destroy the transformer
stations that keep our grid running
this has happened already like when the
quebec power grid failed after a strong
solar storm in 1989
but in general our engineers know how to
deal with these storms and so we usually
don't even notice
the last time a solar hurricane washed
over earth was in 1859 the carrington
event the largest geomagnetic storms
ever observed on earth
massive auroras occurred as far south as
the caribbean
in some places they were so bright that
people got up thinking the sun was
rising luckily we only had one sort of
modern technology telegraph systems
they failed all over the world shocking
their operators and chucking out sparks
today we have a tad more technology and
our luck may run out soon another bad
solar storm is bound to happen
eventually
a storm as strong as the carrington
event missed earth only by a small
margin in 2012.
studies projected that it would have
inflicted serious damage to electronic
systems globally costing up to 2.6
trillion dollars to the us alone
the time to replace all the damaged
systems was estimated at between 4 and
10 years
it's hard to say how bad it could have
been
experts disagreed some assumed there
would just be temporary blackouts but
others worried it could be much worse
we won't know for sure until a big solar
hurricane hits us
the probability of such an event is
estimated to be 12 per decade that's
about a 50 50 chance of at least one in
the next 50 years
and there is more unsettling news
a 2019 paper found that even calm stars
like our sun can create super flares
every few thousand years
eruptions orders of magnitude stronger
than the strongest storms we have
observed in the solar system
if such a storm hits us unprepared the
consequences could be catastrophic
it's hard to overstate how much we
depend on electricity it's not just the
lights at home it means no computers no
communication no navigation a sustained
power outage might lead to a breakdown
of the supply chain water supply systems
failing and hospital generators running
dry
supermarkets not being refilled while
food rots in the fields
the lack of power might make it
extremely hard to reboot our broken
power grid taking years or decades to
restart our starving civilization
okay time to panic
as much as daily newspapers might like
for solar storms to send us back to the
stone age they probably won't
fortunately even though solar storms
aren't preventable virtually all of
their nasty side effects are
scientists observing the sun have a few
hours up to a few days to see a cme
coming
and the engineers working the systems
that keep the world running are well
aware of the risks posed by solar storms
transformers and substations can be
taken offline
short preventative blackouts or in other
words by unplugging stuff
engineers can open up extra lines to
dissipate the extra power
and with investment and upgrades cheap
compared to those other natural
disasters require we could protect the
world's electric grid against even the
nastiest of storms
but we do need to prepare
while the risk is manageable it is real
for while our sun bathes us in warm and
pleasant light one day it might send a
monster our way that we better be ready
for
this video was sponsored by you
court cassand videos are only possible
thanks to your direct support for
example if you want to stare at our
smooth and round sun for a little longer
we've made two minimal infographic
posters one about the scale of the sun
and one about the age of the universe
both should make you feel sufficiently
tiny and help you appreciate your
existence a bit more
but wait there's more we have a bunch of
new stuff from the long requested
bacteriophage infographic poster to a
new optimistic nihilism poster that lets
you enjoy some existential dread in
style
or join us in our ant obsession and get
the new ant explorer notebook with
beautiful infographics and facts about
ants and gold lettering on the cover if
you'd rather update your wardrobe have a
look at our beanies or t-shirts or you
know all the other stuff we put a lot of
love and care into developing our
products and only make stuff we want to
have ourselves if you want to support
quotes because getting some merch is the
best way to do it while receiving
something beautiful in return thank you
for your support and thank you for
watching
[Music]
[Music]
you